I want to continue in Volume 2 and take up at April 26, 1899. And here the Lord is speaking
about attachment. He will bring up this subject over and over again because it's one of the
vital lessons in life. We cannot leave this earth with any baggage that isn't spiritual
and so we have to learn how to be detached from people and things and ourselves and our own
opinion and all kinds of stuff, if we're to be free enough to be able to be in the divine will.
Today, while my beloved Jesus was making himself seen, it seemed to me that he was sending me
many flashes of light which penetrated all through of me, through all of me. When in one instant,
I found myself outside of myself together with him and the confessor was there.
She has had this experience before that in and out of the body experience. She can experience the
confessor and the Lord together. Immediately, I prayed my beloved Jesus to give a kiss to the
confessor and to go into his arms for a little while because Jesus was showing himself as a child.
To make me content immediately, he kissed the confessor on his face but without wanting to detach
from me. I remained all afflicted, she said, and I said to him, "My little treasure,
my intention was for you to kiss not his face but his mouth so that touched by your most pure
lips it might be sanctified and strengthened from that weakness." She's referring to something that
Jesus and herself understood. In this way, it will be able to announce your holy word more freely
and to sanctify others. "Oh, please, I pray you to make me content." So Jesus gave me another
kiss on the mouth and then he said, "I am so very pleased with the souls who are detached from
everything. Not only in the effect but also in the effect. Not only in the doing of their works
but also in the results of their works. And as they keep stripping themselves, my light keeps
investing them and they become just like crystals. That means that the light can shine through them.
Such that the light of the sun finds no impediment to penetration inside of them
unlike buildings which are thick and heavy and other material things. So we have to be detached
in order to become spiritual." Then he added, "Ah, they think that they strip themselves but instead
they come to be clothed not only with spiritual things but also with corporal ones because my
providence has a care, all particular and special for those detached souls. My providence covers them
everywhere. It happens that they have nothing and yet they possess everything." That's what St. Paul
says in 2 Corinthians 6, 10, that as having nothing we possess all things. Now the problem
that most of us have is that we don't trust God really to provide all our needs. So we make
absolutely certain that we provide them ourselves. And then we wonder why we don't have a testimony
that other people have who let stuff go and trust in God absolutely to take care of them.
After this we withdrew from the Confessor and we found many religious people who
seemed all to have their goals set on working for their own interest. You see they're not trusting
God. Passing through their midst, Jesus said, "Woe, woe to one who works for the purpose of
gaining money. You've already received your recompense." Okay. Now it's not what it looks like.
In Italy in those days, families insisted on priests running their businesses for them
because their priest would be trusted as being honest, whereas they wouldn't trust anybody else.
And so they pulled priests away from their vocations and got them totally involved in commercial
things. And then the priest became attached to things and he got wealthy and his vocation is
destroyed. So that's what he means by working for their own interest and if they're only interested
in gaining money. It's a terrible danger for someone like a priest or a bishop or a cardinal
to be given property and money and then they get involved in the whole commercial world.
So me the second 1899, how all heaven is veiled in the church. This morning Jesus aroused
much compassion. He was so afflicted and in suffering that I wouldn't dare to ask him anything.
We would look at each other in silence. Every now and then he would give me a kiss and I would kiss
him and he continued to make himself seen in this way several times. On the last occasion,
he made me see the church telling me these exact words. All heaven is veiled in my church.
Just as in heaven, God is the head and there are many saints of different conditions,
orders and merits. So in my church, in which all heaven is veiled, the pope is the head
and the sacrosanct Trinity is veiled even in the triple tiara that covers his head.
And there are many members who depend on this head. That is different. Dignity is various
orders superior inferior from the littlest to the greatest. They all serve to embellish my church.
Each one according to his degree has the office entrusted to it. And by the exact fulfillment of
the virtues, it comes to give from itself a splendor so very fragrant to my church
that the earth and heaven are perfumed and illuminated. And the people are so drawn by this light and
by this fragrance that it is almost impossible for them not to surrender to the truth.
I leave it to you then to consider those infected members, which instead of shedding light, they
cast darkness. How much torment they cause my church. And so this is the reason why Jesus shows
himself all afflicted and everything. He's illustrating for Louisa the damage that is being
done to the church through sin and through getting involved in worldliness and self and all the rest
of it. While Jesus was saying this, I saw the confessor near him. Jesus stared hard at him
just as he did to the rich young man in the gospel. Do you remember? With his penetrating gaze,
then he turned and he told me, I want you to have full confidence in the confessor even in the
smallest things. So much so that there must be no difference for you between me and him.
And according to your confidence and faith in his words, so I will concur. So there's Jesus telling
her to have absolute confidence in this priest. And that in other words, she could trust that God
was guiding the priest to guide her. Now, who is this priest? The confessor from 1898 to 1922
is Father Gennaro di Gennaro, a huge influence on Louisa's life. He's not canonized though. The
only one of our confessors who was canonized was Annabel de Francia. So in the very act in which
Jesus was saying these words, I remembered about certain temptations of the devil, which had produced
a little bit of distrust in me. But Jesus with his vigilant eye immediately corrected me.
And at that very moment, I felt that distrust being removed from within my interior. May the
Lord be always blessed, who has so much care for the soul, so miserable and sinful.
So May the sixth 1899, Louisa looks for Jesus among the angels.
This morning, Jesus hardly made himself seen. I was feeling my mind so confused that I almost
could not understand the loss of Jesus. When I felt surrounded by many spirits, maybe they were
angels, I cannot tell with certainty. While I was in there midst, every now and then I would
investigate, who knows, I might feel at least the breath of my beloved. But as much as I did,
I found nothing that would reveal the presence of my loving good. Then all of a sudden, I felt a
sweet breath coming from behind my shoulders, and I immediately cried out, Jesus, my Lord.
And he said, Louisa, what do you want? Now, I want to remind you that in John 20 verses 1 to 10,
on Easter day, Mary of Magdalene went looking for Jesus. She wanted him so badly that when she
met the angels, she paid no attention to them. It's very interesting. Also, when you go to the
Song of Songs, chapter 3 verses 1 to 5, you have the spouse in the Song of Songs searching for her
beloved so much that it doesn't matter who else she meets, she has no interest in them, whatever.
And that's the same with Louisa here. Jesus, my beautiful one Louisa said, come, do not remain
behind my shoulders, for I cannot see you. She desperately needs to see him. I've been waiting
for you and investigating for the whole morning, who knows, I might see you amid all these angelic
spirits around my bed. But I couldn't, and therefore I feel very tired because I can find no rest
without you. Come, we will rest together. So Jesus placed himself near me and sustained my head.
Those spirits said, Lord, how quickly she recognized you, not even at your voice,
but at your mere breath immediately she called you. And Jesus answered them,
she knows me, and I know her. That's John 10, 14, my sheep know my voice, and they recognize me.
She is so very dear to me, like the pupil of my eyes.
And while he was saying this, I found myself in the eyes of Jesus, who can say what I felt
being in those most pure eyes, it's impossible to manifest it with words. The very angels remained
astonished. So May the seventh 1899, here we come to purity of intention. In the first four volumes,
this with the detachment, this subject is brought back time after time, because it is so essential
for us making a successful journey in the divine will. So when I was doing my meditation during the
day, Jesus kept making himself seen near me, and he told me, my person is surrounded by all the
works that souls do, as by a garment, and the more purity of intention and intensity of love
that they have, the more splendor they give me. And I will give them more glory, so much so that
on the day of judgment, I will show them to the whole world. So let the whole world know how my
children have honored me and how I honor them. That's the first book of Samuel chapter 2 verse 30,
"Those who honor me, I will honor," says the Lord.
Assuming a more afflicted heir, he said, "My daughter, what will happen to so many works,
even good ones, done without purity of intention, or simply out of habit or self-interest? What
shame will not fall upon them on the day of judgment and seeing so many works good in themselves,
but made rotten by their bad intention, bad understood? Such that their very actions instead
of rendering honor to them, as they would would to many others, will give them shame. In fact,
I do not look at the greatness of works, but at the intention in which they are done."
That's an extremely important point, and Jesus will come back to it time and time and time again,
to make sure that we understand that we could do all the projects on the planet.
But as St. Thereseu said, "That picking up a pin off the floor out of pure love for God
is worth all the projects on the planet." It's the love content that makes all the
difference to God because God is love. He said, "This is where all my attention is."
So Jesus then kept silent for a little while, and Louisa said, "I kept thinking about the words he
had spoken to me while I was meditating within my mind, especially on the purity of intention,
and on the fact that when creatures do good, they must disappear, making the creature one with the
Lord himself as if creatures did not exist." So I want to give you John 3.30 there. "He must
increase, and I must decrease." Now in the divine will journey, we have to decrease to the point
of nothingness so that he can increase to the point of allness in us. Then Jesus continued,
saying to me, "Yes, it is so. See, my heart is so very large, but the door is very narrow."
Now that's Matthew 7 verses 13 to 14. "No one can fill the void of this heart, but souls who are
detached, that nakedness now is your own self-put aside and all your self-interest and everything
to do itself, and simple, simple meaning uncomplicated." Okay. In fact, as you see, since the door is
small, any hindrance, even the slightest, that is a shadow of attachment, an intention that is not
upright, a work done without purpose of pleasing me, all of this prevents them from entering
in order to delight my heart. "Much love of neighbor enters my heart." Now there's a VIP point,
and the only thing that enters his heart is love. That is love for God, love for neighbor.
"Much love of neighbor enters my heart, but it must be so united to mine as to form one single
love." Now that is John 13 verses 34 to 35. "That you are to love one another in the same way as I
loved you." That is absolutely unconditionally with utter forgiveness. And also John 15-9,
"As the Father has loved me, so I have loved you." And that is the way that you are to love one another.
"So the love must be united to mine to form one single love in such a way that one cannot
be distinguished from the other. But as for the other love of neighbor which is not transformed
into my love, I look at it as something. I do not look at it as something that belongs to me."
So it's only the divine love with which we love God with his own love, and we love our neighbor
with God's love. That's the only love that actually means anything. Human love is ephemeral,
like the weather it comes and goes. May the 9th, 1899, the threat of chastisement.
This morning I was in a sea of affliction because of the loss of Jesus. After a much hardship,
Jesus came and drew so close to me that I couldn't even see him. He reached the point of placing his
forehead upon mine, of leaning his face on mine, and so with all the other members. So this is
complete oneness. Now, while Jesus was in this position, I said to him, "My adorable Jesus,
you don't love me anymore." It's a totally extraordinary day. And he coming to give her this
extraordinary intimacy. He said, "If I didn't love you, would I not be so close to you?"
And Louisa said, "Well, how can you say that you love me if you no longer let me suffer as
before? I'm afraid you don't want me to be in this state anymore, at least free me also from the
bother of the confessor." Now, Louisa has a thorn in her side, and the thorn in her side is that the
confessor must come every single day to release her from the stiffness that her body goes into
when she's in ecstasy. She can't release it herself. She's willing to suffer the crown of thorns,
to be crucified, to carry the cross, blah, blah, blah, but not this. If you want to know what your
cross says, all you have to do is look at whatever it is in your life that you would give to anybody
anywhere, anytime, under any condition, Venito. That's your cross. A cross is unbearable.
And this is what Louisa had, but she never recognized it as a cross. It's amazing. And very often,
the things that cause us the most pain are unrecognized either. It's very interesting.
It may be a struggle that you have inside of you. It may be a difficulty you have in a relationship.
It could be anything. It could be illness that you don't want.
It's something that's really challenging you at the core of your being.
So Louisa said, while I was saying this, it seemed that Jesus would not pay attention to my words,
but rather he made me see a multitude of people, in other words, he deflected her attention,
who are committing every kind of evil. Indignant with them, Jesus would make different kinds of
contagious diseases swoop down into their midst. And many would die black as charcoal.
Now, if your soul is as black as charcoal, you're not going to heaven. And it doesn't appear that
you're going to purgatory either. It seemed that Jesus would exterminate that multitude of people
from the face of the earth. That's Revelation 11, 18. I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
While seeing this, I prayed Jesus to pour his bitterness into me so as to spare the people,
but he wouldn't pay attention to me in this either. And replying to the words I had said before,
he said, "The greatest chastisement I can give you, the priest and the people,
is to free you from the state of suffering." In other words, Louisa's going to discover,
but only in Volume 6, when Jesus tells her that the whole of Europe is on her back.
And yes, there was going to be two terrible wars, but they would have been infinitely worse
if she wasn't carrying out her role as victim soul. So Louisa has to stand in the breach between
the justice of God and the sinfulness of man. That's Sam 106, verse 23. There's also a passage in
Isaiah where the prophet complains that there was nobody to stand in the breach.
My justice would pour out in all its fury if there was no victim soul understood,
because it would find no opposition. This is so true that the worst evil for someone
is to be given an office and then be removed from it, because there would be a terrifying
judgment for her that she was asked to love her neighbor like this and she was refusing to do it.
It will be better for him that he had not been admitted to that office since by abusing it and
not profiting from it, he has rendered himself unworthy of it. Oh dear, remember Judas. He was
called to very high office. He was given all the privileges of that office. He preached Christ,
he worked miracles for him, and he betrayed him and lost his soul. Then Jesus continued to come
quite a few times today, but so afflicted us to move on to pity and to tears, maybe even the
stones, we'd say to move the stones to tears here. I tried to console him as much as I could.
At one time I would embrace him and then at another I would sustain his head, which was in great
pain, or I would say to him, heart of my heart Jesus. It has never been your usual way to appear
so afflicted to me. In other words, you made yourself so afflicted by pouring it into me.
If other times you made yourself seem afflicted by pouring yourself,
pouring it into me, you would immediately change appearance, but now I am being denied the opportunity
to give you this relief. Who would have thought after you had consented to pour and to share your
sufferings with me for so long that you yourself did so much to dispose me that now I would be
deprived of it. Suffering for love of you was my only relief. It was suffering that made me bear
my exile from heaven, but now being deprived of it, I feel I have no place on which to lean
anymore and life becomes tedious. Now, sitting in a bed doing nothing and having no distractions,
tedium is definitely a word that you would use. You'd go off your head completely.
"O please, O holy spouse, beloved good my dear life, O please let the pains come back to me,
give me suffering. Do not look at my unworthiness and at my grave sins, but at your mercy which has
not exhausted itself. While I was pouring myself out with Jesus, he drew closer to me and told me
my daughter, it is my justice that wants to pour itself out onto creatures. The number of sins in
men is almost complete. Now, this is only 1899. What would it be like in the third millennium?
I want to give you Genesis 1516. The cup of the Amorites is not yet full. And when their cup of
iniquity is full, that's when chastisement comes hot and heavy down on top of us.
The number of sins of men is almost complete and justice wants to come out to make pomp of its
fury and to find reparation for the injustices of men. Look, to show you how embittered I am and
to content you a little bit, I want to pour only my breath into you. And so drawing his lips near
mine, he sent me his breath which was so bitter that I felt my mouth, my heart and my whole person
being intoxicated. If his mere breath was so bitter, what must the rest of Jesus be like?
He left me with such pain that I felt my heart pierced through. In other words, he's letting her
know what he means by the cup of iniquity is almost full. He only gave her one breath of it and it
was intolerable for her. We have no idea what sin is like. We've no idea the effect it has
on heaven, on the Lord and the damage it's doing to the earth itself. You might know something
intellectually, but to know it is to grasp it in the depths of your soul. I think we'd all be doing
reparation morning, noon and night if we understood. So May 12, 1899, Jesus makes her content pouring
sweetness and bitterness from his side. This morning, continuing to make himself seen afflicted,
my adorable Jesus transported me outside of myself and showed me the various offenses that he was
receiving. Now notice receiving in the present tense. That's 1899. I began to pray again that he
would pour his bitterness into me. At the beginning, Jesus did not pay attention to me and he just
told me, my daughter, only then is divine love perfect when it is done for the soul purpose of
pleasing me. He says charity and I'm saying divine love to make sure you understand it's not just
human love. Only karitas or agape, they're the Latin and the Greek, when agape is really perfect,
it's when it's done solely for the purpose of pleasing me. So if you want to make an act of pure
love, it has to be only and absolutely to please Jesus for no other reason. Otherwise, it's not
taken as a complete act of love. And only then is it called true charity and is it recognized by me
when it is stripped of everything. That is stripped of self-seeking, stripped of wanting
recompense from human beings, stripped from needing praise, stripped from needing thanks
and all the rest and all the rest. So I want to give you John 544, where Jesus told the scribes
and Pharisees that they were looking for human recompense and therefore they were getting
known from heaven. Also in Matthew chapter 6, at least verses 1 to 10, you have Jesus saying that
because of the way they were praying, they had got their reward, there would be no reward coming
to them from heaven and the way they were strutting about and looking for the honor and glory of human
beings, there was no honor and glory due to them from God said. So taking the occasion from his
very words, Louisa said to him, "Jesus my dear, it's precisely for this that I want you to pour your
bitterness into me, to be able to relieve you from so many pains. And if I pray you also to spare
the rest of the humans, it is because I remember well that on other occasions after you had chastised
them in seeing you suffer so much from poverty and other things, you too suffered very much."
Also in seeing them suffer as a result of the chastisement, you too suffered. That's like saying
a parent who has to chastise a child when the chastisements really need it. They don't enjoy
it and they don't enjoy the unhappiness of the child and they don't enjoy the atmosphere that is
created. They don't enjoy any of it. They only enjoy it when the child is happy and fulfilled.
On the other hand, when I have been attentive and I have prayed you and importuned you to the point
of tiring you so much so that you were pleased to pour it into me, sparing them, afterwards you
have been very content about it. Don't you remember? Besides, are they no longer your images? That's
Genesis 1.27 and Genesis 5.3 and Romans 8.29 and 2 Corinthians 3.18.
"Seeing himself persuaded, Jesus told me, because of you, it's necessary to make you content.
Draw near me and drink from my side." That's the great wound in his side.
"So I did," Louisa said. "I drew near him to drink from his side, but instead of bitterness,
I suckled a most sweet blood which inebriated all of me with love and with sweetness,
because the whole of redemption is in the precious blood of the Lamb," as St. John tells us in his
letters. "Yes, I was content, but this wasn't my intention." He wasn't looking for that.
So turning to him, I said, "My dear good, what are you doing? What comes out is not bitter,
but sweet, oh please, I pray you, pour your own bitterness into me, and Jesus, looking at me
kindly, told me, keep drinking from bitter, for the bitter comes afterwards."
Now, the interesting thing is that both in the Old Testament and in the book of Revelation,
I'll give you Revelation 10, 9. When the prophets were told to eat the scroll,
they found it sweet initially, and then it turned bitter in their stomach.
And what that meant was that they enjoyed receiving the word of God. But when the reality of what
the word of God meant for human beings and they were to deliver it, it was going to cost them an
awful lot of pain to deliver an unwelcome message to an unwilling audience. And most of the prophets
were martyred as a result. So Louisa said, "I attached myself to a side again, and after the
sweet kept coming for a while, the bitter also came. But who can say the intensity of the bitterness?
Afterwards, I was satiated from drinking. I got up, and looking at his head, which had
the crown of thorns, I removed it, and I drove it on to my own head. If this lady can be called
anything, she can be called very courageous." Jesus seemed to be all compliant, while other
times he had not permitted this. How beautiful it was to see Jesus after he had poured his bitterness,
he seemed almost disarmed without strength, all meek, like a humble little lamb. In other
words, this is the power of the victim soul to change justice into meekness.
"I realized that it was very late," she said. "But since the confessor had come early in the
morning to call me to obedience, it wasn't that I knew that I was to be called by obedience. For
at the obedience, Jesus leaves me free." So turning to him, I said, "Most sweet Jesus, do not allow
that I cause trouble to my family and bother to the confessor by having him come again."
There's the thorn in her side. "Oh, please, I beg you, you yourself, let me return into myself."
And Jesus told me, "My daughter, today, I do not want to leave you."
And Louisa said, "I too do not want to do not have the heart to leave you. But just for a little
to let my family see that I am inside of myself, and then we will return and be together."
So after a long differing, so here they are disagreeing together. Okay? So this is a sweet
little row between two spouses. Saying goodbye to each other, he left me for a little while.
It was precisely lunchtime and my family was just coming to call me. But even though I felt I was
inside of myself, I felt all full of suffering my head would not hold up. That bitter and that
sweet which I had drunk from the side of Jesus gave me such satiety and suffering together,
that it was impossible for me to take anything else. The word I had given to Jesus kept me
on tender hooks. So with the pretext that my head was aching, I said to my family, let me be alone
for I do not want anything. So I was left free again. And immediately I began to call my sweet
Jesus and he always kind came back. But who can say what happened to me today? How many graces Jesus
gave to my soul? How many things he made me understand? It is impossible to express it in words.
Then after staying for a long time in order to cam my sufferings, Jesus poured sweet milk
from his mouth. Now a lot of the saints and mystics have had this sweet milk and it seems to be
a fortifying food. And I remember saying to a class recently, I don't understand this milk and
immediately the Lord gave me an image of the milk. And that it is that when an infant sucks its
mother's breast, it is receiving life from its source, because the mother was the source of that
life. And when Jesus gives milk from his mouth to the saints, they are feeding directly from the
source of life. And he's strengthening them for all that they have to suffer. So he left me then,
giving me his word that he would come back soon. And so I found myself inside myself again, but a
little more free of sufferings. Now it's on a day like that that Louisa is completely spoiled.
Jesus is with her most of the time and there's wonderful things going on between them. So as
soon as he has to pull back and give her a little bit of privation, then she goes into an absolute
tailspin. So May the 16th 1899, this is the power of the cross and stripping oneself of one's own
will. So this is a VIP message you need to put VIP on it, because it is absolutely central to the
journey of the divine will. Jesus continued for a few more days to manifest himself in the same way,
not wanting to detach himself from me. It seemed that that little bit of sufferings he had poured
into me attracted him so much that he couldn't be without me. This morning he poured a little bit
more of bitterness from his mouth into mine. And then he told me, the cross disposes the soul to
patience. Now anyone who's been through a long trial, you will know that the thing you learn is
patience. And patience means long suffering. And long suffering means L with a mile, O with another
mile, N with another mile, and then G. It really means long suffering. Most people are very impatient
and they go mad if they're left waiting a moment even. Nowadays, they're so used to machines that
if the machine doesn't operate instantly, they absolutely, I'm waiting ages and it mightn't even
be a minute. If no patience at all. Now the cross disposes the soul to patience. The cross opens
heaven and it unites heaven and earth together. That is, it unites God and the soul. The power of
the cross is very great. And when it enters a soul, it has the virtue of removing the rust
of all earthly things. Not only this, but it causes her boredom, bother and contempt for the
things of the earth, giving her instead the flavor and the enjoyment of celestial things.
So one of the great things that the cross does is to heal us of our attachment to earthly things
and to turn us around and redirect us towards heaven.
However, few are those who recognize the power of the cross and therefore they despise it.
So I want to give you Matthew 1624. Peter absolutely rejected the cross when he heard it.
And then Jesus told him that the cross was for every one of his disciples. In other words,
many of the saints have said that a Christian without a cross is an anachronism.
Who could say how many things I understood about the cross while Jesus was speaking?
Jesus' teaching is not like ours in which one understands only so much of what is said.
Rather, one single word of his contains immense light because Jesus is the creative word of God.
That's John 1, 1 to 5. So every single word of his leaves an immense light and to ruminate well
on it one could remain occupied the whole day in the most profound meditation. Therefore,
if I wanted to tell everything it would be too long and I would also lack the time to do it.
So after a little while Jesus came back again with a little more afflicted.
I immediately asked the reason for it and Jesus showed me many devout souls. Now that usually
means priests and religious. That means hierarchy, priests and religious. And he told me, my daughter,
what I look at in the soul is when she strips herself of her will.
Only then does my will invest her, divinise her and make her all mine. Now that is VIP.
The motto that we have to have in the divine will adventure is not my will, but thine be done.
And if we're not stripping ourselves on a daily basis of our will, the divine will cannot take
over. It's actually that simple. If I have a cup full of tea, I cannot drink water. I have
to pour out the tea to put the water in or vice versa. So if I want to be filled with divine will,
the human will has got to step down. And so if we're not doing that, you can say all the prayers
you like in the divine will, but you are not on this journey. On this journey, you strip yourself
of the human will to let the divine will take over. Take a look at these souls, Jesus said,
who call themselves devout, as long as they get things their own way.
But then one little thing if their confessions are not long enough, if the competitor does not
satisfy them, it's enough for them to lose all peace. And some reach the point of no longer wanting
to do anything. This says that it's not my will that predominates in them. It is their own.
Believe me, my daughter, that they have taken the wrong path. That's Matthew seven versus 13 to 14.
Because when I see that they really want to love me, I have many ways to give grace.
How pitiful it was to see Jesus suffer for this kind of people. I tried to sympathize with him as
much as I could and so it ended. Now look, let me give you an example. I've given retreats for
more than 40 years. The people who come on retreat are nuns and priests and brothers and lay people
who are committed to the Lord and they want to grow in holiness. So they are the devout,
these people that the Lord is talking about here. And my experience has been that while they
want to go on retreat, they won't keep the silence for you. They want the best rooms.
They will complain if the standard isn't high enough. They complain if the food isn't the best
and if the portions of food aren't big enough. They want the best seats in the hall where you're
speaking. And I just look at it and say, they're deceiving themselves. They think they're seeking
God, but they're not. They're not seeking God. If you're looking for your own comfort and for all
the advantages that you can possibly get in a situation, you're not seeking God. You're seeking
yourself. And if you're seeking yourself, forget about divine will. Divine will won't enter.
And so the very basic step is that we've got to set aside our own will and the seeking of self
and the seeking of comfort for ourselves. We've got to set that aside and seek God for himself alone.
So we now come to May the 19th, 1899. This is a very important message as well,
and it's one of the foundational messages. You see, in volumes one to four, you get all the
foundational messages. Some people think you can start reading these volumes at higher volumes,
but if you don't have the foundation stones, you may not actually reach divine will.
This morning, I felt a fear within me that it might not be Jesus, but the devil who wanted to
deceive me. Jesus came and seeing me with this fear, he said to me, humility is the safeguard
of celestial favors. Do you remember Blessed Mother in the Magnificat in Luke chapter one?
He who is mighty has done great things for me and holy is his name. And she described herself as
his lowly servant. Okay. Humility is the safeguard. It's the only safe place we can be
in the spiritual life. Humility clothes the soul with such safety that the tricks of the devil
cannot penetrate into her. Humility places all celestial graces in safety, so much so that when
I see humility, I let flow abundantly all kinds of celestial favors. Therefore, do not want to
disturb yourself for this, but rather with the simple eye, look always into your interior to see
whether you are invested with beautiful humility and do not worry about all the rest.
Then he showed me many religious people and among them priests, even of holy life, but as good as
they were, they lacked that spirit of simplicity. Now that's Matthew 18 verses 1 to 4. The simplicity
is a different word to the word that's used out in the world, simple meaning that you're not really
intelligent. Simple means not complicated, that your soul is limpered, that it's like it's crystal
clear and there's no complications there for the devil to hide in. They lacked that spirit of
simplicity in believing in the many graces and the many ways that the Lord uses with the souls.
Jesus said to me, "I communicate myself both to the humble and to the simple." Now all you've got to
do is read the lives of all the saints you know and that's the truth. Look at the extraordinary
message given to burn it out of lords, who only walked into a school at the age of 11 in order
to prepare for holy communion. That was the end of our schooling. Louisa Picaretta had no schooling.
You find many of the saints whom the Lord has chosen. He has chosen them so that they were not
influenced by the world and therefore they could receive an incredible message from him.
The humble and the simple. Look at the children of Fatima, the children of Garibandal,
the children of La Salette. Look at Luke chapter 1 verse 46. He pulls the mighty from their thrones
and raises the lowly. I communicate myself both to the humble and to the the simple or the lowly
because they immediately believe in my graces and take them into great consideration,
though they may be ignorant and poor ignorant meaning have no schooling and poor having no money
as was the case of burn it at and so on. But with these others who have all the education
and the good background and all the rest of it. I'm very reluctant because the first step which
draws the soul near me is faith. That's if he uses the word belief that means a living faith.
And it happens that these with all of their knowledge and doctrine and even holiness
never come to experience even one ray of celestial light. Now I mean that's an
offer and complete tragedy. So they have their university degrees and their professorships and
their this and that and the others and they've written books and they've been they they're famous
and they're speeches and they've got big jobs in the church. But if they've never experienced even
one ray of celestial light don't you think they're the poorest of the poor? In other words Jesus said
they walk a natural path and they never arrive at touching even slightly that which is supernatural.
Well that explains how priests and bishops and cardinals can go astray.
They don't even touch the supernatural even slightly. This is also the reason for which in the course
of my mortal life there was not one learned man not one priest one man of power among my followers
it was all the little people. But all were ignorant and of low condition because these were humble and
simple and also more disposed to make great sacrifices for me. So I want to give you one Peter five
five to nine. I want to give you Matthew five verses three to twelve and I want to give you one
Corinthians one verses twenty six to thirty one in which Paul says now look at us after the
resurrection the church is now on its feet. He says who are the people whom the Lord is calling
isn't it the poor and so on. We know that the first four or five popes were ex-slaves for example.
May the 23rd 1899 here we have again Jesus comes back to detachment from oneself an extremely
important message. This time my adorable Jesus wanted to play a little bit he would come he would
show that he wanted to listen to me but as soon as I would begin to speak he would disappear from me
like a flash and she says oh God what pain. While my heart was swimming in the most bitter pain of
Jesus's distance and it was almost a little restless Jesus came back again telling me what is it what
is it now be more peaceful and more calm speak speak what do you want and the moment I spoke he
disappeared. I did as much as I could to calm myself but no after a while my heart returned to
being unable to give itself peace without its only and soul comfort and maybe more than before
coming back again Jesus told me my daughter sweetness has the power of making things change
their nature. Now she doesn't show sweetness in his absence she only shows sorrow and grief and
disturbance and he's trying to tell her to stop complaining he's also trying to tell her that she
must give him the freedom to come and go as he pleases she's got to let him be free whereas her
instinct is to draw him close to herself and hold him close to herself and all the rest of it and
she's got to become more free than that she's got to let him go. Now that's going to be a hard lesson
for Louisa. So he said sweetness has the power of making things change their nature it knows well
how to convert bitter into sweet therefore more sweet more sweet he said but he gave me no time
to say a word because it wouldn't be sweet you see and so this is how I spent the morning after
this I felt I was outside of myself together with Jesus there were many people some who aspired to
riches some to honor some to glory and some even to sanctity but many other things but not for God
this is very interesting you might want to be a saint but it's for yourself that you want to
become perfect and you want to be famous and you want to be canonized and you want to have a great
place in heaven what about God what about God's glory it's all about loving God the whole thing
is about loving God and she said so these people were some of them aspired to riches
honor glory even to sanctity but not for God and rather to be considered someone that's the important
thing in other words even if they wanted to become saints it was that they wanted to become
someone special turning to them shaking his head Jesus says foolish that you are you are working
your own net to entangle yourselves it's very sad john 544 Jesus said you look to one another
for approval and you don't seek the approval of the one god then turning to me he told me my daughter
this is why the first thing I recommend is detachment from all things also from yourself
in other words you're not looking for your own sanctity you're not looking for your own this that
or the other when the soul has detached herself from everything she has no need to struggle in
order to stay away from the things of the earth which by themselves come around her
in other words we're on the earth so you have to be surrounded by the things of the earth but it's
not going to affect you if you're really free but rather in seeing themselves ignored and even more
despised saying goodbye to her they take like leave of her and they don't bother her anymore
so if you've become free of something it's not going to bother you
the amazing thing is that when I turned off the radio more than 20 years ago I don't even think
radio not only do I not think I'm missing anything but the word itself doesn't come into my head
but all the peace and freedom and everything else that you get by not having all these voices
coming in on top of you with all the different opinions of the world whoa that's wonderful
do you miss that no you don't what you find is that you've shut off that cacophony of voices
and you've allowed yourself the freedom to hear the voice of god
so may the 26th 1899 contempt of oneself must be united to faith so this is a message in which
we're talking about true self knowledge this morning I was in such a state of annihilation of myself
louisis has to the point of feeling obnoxious and annoyed it seemed to me that I was the most
abominable being that could be found I saw myself like a little worm that tossed and turned but
remained always there in the mode unable to take a step oh god what human misery yet after I have
been given so many graces and still so bad so put john 15 5 there without me Jesus said you can do
nothing I think we've all proved that one without him we can do nothing except sin
my good Jesus always kind with this miserable sinner came and he told me contempt of yourself
is praiseworthy when it is well invested with the spirit of faith now contempt of yourself
when it is not invested with the spirit of faith can be very dangerous because it could lead you
to suicide and contempt of oneself is that not only are you not blowing yourself up you are
simply not giving yourself the attention that others give themselves and it when it is well
invested with the spirit of faith but when it is not invested with the spirit of faith instead
of doing you good it will harm you in fact in seeing yourself as you are unable to do anything
good you'll become discouraged disheartened and of course that leads to suicide in people who have
no faith without daring to take one step on the path of good but by leaning on me that's your
Philippians 4 13 I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength that is by investing
yourself with the spirit of faith you will come to know and despise yourself and at the same time
you will come to know me confident of being able to do anything with my help that's exactly
what Paul says in Philippians 4 13 I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength
and here is how by acting in this way you will walk according to the truth
Louisa said how much good these words of Jesus have done to my soul I understood that I must
enter into my nothingness now you see this is the important bit okay so I think it would be
good to write nothingness at the top of the page here and to enter into my nothingness
and know who I am but I must not stop there rather immediately after I have known myself I must fly
into the immense sea of God and stop there when a child feels weak or challenged or has cut its
knees or dirties its clothes or whatever what's to do run straight into the arms of its mother
and the Lord wants us to run straight into his arms he is everything we are not okay
rather after I have known myself I must fly into the immense sea of God and stop there
to draw all the graces that my soul needs otherwise my human nature becomes weary
and the devil will look for the opportunity in order to cast you into discouragement
and discouragement is a terrible place to be made the Lord be always blessed and may everything be
for his glory so we'll do another one made the 31st 1899 opposition serves so that the truth may
shine in other words when we're serving God you can expect opposition but the Lord uses it
this morning as I was in my usual state my adorable Jesus came and at that very moment I saw the
confessor Jesus appeared a little disappointed with him because it seemed that the confessor wanted
everyone to approve that my situation was a work from God and almost wanted to convince other
priests by showing them something of my interior Jesus turned to the confessor and said to him
this is impossible even I received opposition and I received it from the most distinguished people
also from priests and other authorities they found fault with my holy works as John 848
aren't you a Samaritan and a devil to the point of saying that I was possessed by the devil
but I allowed these oppositions even from religious people so that the truth may shine
in its own time now that's the important bit see the opposition is going to be good for
Louise's own growth but we who are living a century afterwards can see that all the signs of authenticity
are there if you want to consult with two or three priests among the most good and holy and also
the most learned in order to receive enlightenment and also to do what I want in the things to be
done which is advice from the good and prayer this is I love but the rest no no it would be as
though wanting to waste my works making fun of them which displeases me very much and then he said to
me all I want from you is an upright and simple way of working do not bother about the prose and
cons of creatures let them think what they want without being in the least troubled
since wanting that everything be favorable is wanting to deviate from the imitation of my own
life and this is extremely important Jesus is telling us look if you're going to live a spiritual
life you will find opposition that's just the way it is but if you're going to bother that your
neighbors don't approve of you or somebody doesn't think you're the greatest thing that came upon
the planet if that's going to bother you then you are not free enough to serve God and so Jesus
wants us to be completely free it doesn't matter if someone doesn't think you're authentic when you
know you are the little bit of humility again will actually do you good and so let everybody think
what they want and whatever you do don't defend yourself don't defend yourself let them do what
they want and let God does do what he wants that's the beautiful thing so we have to be free to really
let God be God so I'm going to stop there just now